y Angola han ha cerrado un acuerdo para
ayudar al desarrollo de la agricultura y
de la agroalimentación en ese en ese
país debido a que Angola pues la mayoría
de su digamos economía se ha venido
desarrollando sobre todo en torno a la
explotación de petróleo y por eso
importan la mayoría de alimentos Así que
con este acuerdo Se espera diversificar
a su economía y darle también un nuevo
impulso al sector de la café además de
esto se anunció un préstamo de unos 150
millones de euros a ese país que
entregará la agencia francesa de
desarrollo lo que ellos han llamado un
programa de resiliencia climática
Emmanuel macotra cerrar este acuerdo
decía que este es un ejemplo de lo que
él aspira sean de aquí en adelante las
relaciones de Francia con los demás
países africanos donde Francia pueda
aportar su conocimiento en sectores en
donde se le pidan él estuvo acompañado
allí por cerca de 50 empresas francesas
empresas privadas que también pues
vinieron allí por parte sobre todo
empresas de ganadería y también de cul
tivadores de cereales luego de esto el
presidente se entrevistó con Lorenzo
presidente de Angola antes de viajar
ahora a su siguiente destino se trata de
la Congo allí tendrá también pues se
entrevistará con el presidente de ese
país antes de viajar ya en la noche a el
último lugar que visitará de África que
es Kings antes de regresar a París este
domingo